So congratulations, you just finished unit 1.
You just finished unit 1 of this class,
where I told you about key applications
of artificial intelligence,
I told you about the definition of an intelligent agent,
I gave you 4 key attributes of intelligent agents
(partial observability, stochasticity, continuous spaces, and adversarial natures),
I discussed sources and management of uncertainty,
and I briefly mentioned the mathematical concept of rationality.
Obviously, I only touched any of these issues superficially,
but as this class goes on you're going to dive into any of those
and learn much more about
what it takes to make a truly intelligent AI system.
Thank you.